هنا لا صوت يعلو على صوت ناخب تجربه لم
يعتد عليها محمد من قبل محمد السوري الذي
سقطت عنه صفه اللاجئ وبات اليوم مواطنا
تركيا مارس حقوقه الانتخابيه واختار من
بين مرشح الرئاسه من تمكن من اقناعه
بتنفيذ مصالحه ومتطلباته تجربه يعني جديره
بالاهتمام
مهمه بالنسبه الي يعني تكاد تكون يعني حل
بسيط لكل مشاكلنا المعقده ان يلجا الفرقاء
او من يريد يعني ان يدير البلد او الشخص
ليرى او الحزب الذي يرى في نفسه الاهليه
لقياده هذا يتقدم الى الناس يشرح خطته
يشرح برامج للناس والناس بكل بساطه وسلاسه
ممكن يعني تدلي بصوتها بحيث يعني ينال
الرضا
ينال القبول ينال الشرعيه من الناس وصلت
اعداد السوريين الحاصلين على الجنسيه
التركيه
230 الفا بينهم 130 الفا يحق لهم ان
يصوتوا في هذه الانتخابات التي يشاركون
فيها بعيدا عن موطنهم الاصلي
يترقب السوريون على هذا الجانب من الحدود
نتائج المعركه الانتخابيه التركيه وكيف
ستنعكس على حالهم وحياتهم
تتاثر مناطق شمال غربي سوريا وخاصه منطقتي
الابيض وراس العين بالنظام السياسي التركي
واي تغييرات قد تشهدها فيعيش في المنطقه
ما يقارب من اربعه ملايين ونصف المليون
نسمه غالبيتهم يحتاجون للمساعده وتعتبر
المعابر الحدوديه مع تركيا الشريان الوحيد
لهم كما تتاثر المنطقه اقتصاديا فالتعامل
هنا بالليره التركيه والحركه التجاريه
مرتبطه بالمعابر ايضا والاهم هو الجانب
العسكري والسياسي باعتبار تركيا وسياستها
مع الملف السوري عاملا اساسيا لتحديد
مستقبل المنطقه وخارطه السيطره اليوم حديث
الشارع في المناطق هون عم تتحدث عن
انتخابات التركيه ونتائج الانتخابات تركيا
اكيد في ارتباط وثيق بين انتخابات تركيا
ومصير هذه المناطق وخاصه التجاري او
الصعيد الانساني يرى البعض ان حاله الترقب
هذه لن تنتهي باعلان نتائج الانتخابات
التركيه بل ستستمر حتى تحديد النظام
السياسي التركي وطريقه تعاطيه مع الملف
السوري محمد الاشقر العربي الحدود السوريه
التركيه
لمتابعه المزيد
بالاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات